Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
[Hasan Çolakoğlu
Riot Games Ülke Müdürü]
Herkese merhaba.
Hoşgeldiniz.
Seansımızın konusu oyna.
Bu arkamda gördüğünüz resim,
şu anda sizin bu oturduğunuz salonda,
bundan tam dört hafta önce çekildi.
Ne seyrediyor bu insanlar?
Bu insanlar, sahnede 10 tane oyuncu var.
Yaşları 17 ile 25 yaş arasında değişiyor;
bunlardan 5 tanesi Beşiktaş formasıyla,
5 tanesi de ta Sao Paulo'dan buraya gelip
mücadele eden
INTZ takımının formasını giyiyor.
Bunlar bir elektronik spor
müsabakası yapıyorlar
ve bunun sonunda da büyük bir ödül var.
Kafanızın karıştığını görebiliyorum.
Beşiktaş dedik, elektronik spor dedik,
taraftar dedik,
salonlar dolduruluyor dedik.
Peki, nasıl oluyor da oluyor?
Sizi, benim çok severek içinde bulunduğum
bu yolculuğa benimle birlikte çıkmaya
davet ediyorum.
Bir 17-18 dakika boyunca sizleri
bambaşka bir dünyaya,
bir oyun dünyasına götürmek istiyorum.
Benim adım Hasan Çolakoğlu.
Riot Games ülke müdürüyüm,
ama kendimi hep oyuncu olarak tanımladım.
Bu gördüğünüz resim 1982 yılında
Londra'da çekildi.
Saç dökülmesi işte
böyle bir şey arkadaşlar.
(Kahkaha)
Oğlumun da şu anda bu kadar saçı var.
Bu resmi gördüğünde, bu sen olamazsın
ya da eyvah benim geleceğim falan dedi.
Ama şimdi konumuz o değil,
dediğim gibi ben 35 yıldır oyun oynuyorum.
Sadece bilgisayar ya da konsol oyunları
değil, ne bulursam oynuyorum.
Şöyle ki masaüstünde aklınıza
gelebilecek her türlü oyundan,
FRP'den,
işte arkadaşlarla bir araya geldiğimiz
zaman kendimize oyunlar icat etmeye
çalışarak falan da
vakit geçirdiğimiz zamanlar oldu.
Ama ben 35 yıldır oyun oynuyorum.
Peki bu oyun oynamak nereden çıkmış,
ne olmuş diye yakın zamanda,
yaş da biraz daha büyüyünce fikir
yürütmeye ve bunu araştırmaya başladım.
Bu arada, hayatımı tabii oyun oynamadan
kazanmak yakın zamanki bir hikâye.
20 yıldır bilişim sektöründe çalışıyorum.
11 yıldır da oyun sektöründeyim.
Benim için bu kadar önemli olan oyunları,
Türkiye'deki herkese yayabilmek,
bu sevdiğim şeyi insanlarla paylaşabilmek
için de 11 yıldır çaba gösteriyorum.
Şimdi oyun ne demek?
Oyun, tabii burada bahsettiğimiz;
çocukların, büyüklerin hareketlerini
taklit ederek hayatı öğrendiği
çocuk oyunlarından bahsetmiyoruz.
Genelde işte belli birtakım mekanikleri
olan, belli kurallar çerçevesinde
birtakım stratejiler geliştirerek,
ya da belli noktalarda kendinizi
başka rakiplere karşı üstün
konuma getirmeye çalıştırdığınız
simülasyonlardan bahsediyoruz.
Şöyle bir sorayım öncelikle.
İçinizde ''Ben oyuncuyum,''
diyen kaç kişi var?
Eh, %10 civarında.
İkinci sorum:
Kaç kişi tavla oynadı şimdiye kadar,
hayatında en az bir kere?
Evet, el kaldırmayanlar
varsa da göremiyorum,
kalabalığın arkalarında olsa gerek.
Şimdi ''Ben oyuncu değilim,'' diyen
herkesin bile mutlaka hayatının bir
döneminde tavla oynamışlığı vardır.
Tavlada işte karşımıza çıkan,
bu üst köşede gördüğünüz
''zar'' dediğimiz hadise,
aslında sembolik olarak hayattaki
rastlantısallığı bize anlatan bir objedir.
Ve bilinen en eski zarlar,
3000 yıl önce İran'da bulunmuş.
Sağ üst köşede gördüğünüz oyun,
Mısır'da ilk kraliyet döneminde oynanan
en eski masaüstü oyunu, ismi de senet.
Yani bizim bildiğimiz senet
manasında değil, senet.
Bu kraliyet oyunu da ondan da aşağı yukarı
aynı zamanda oynanmış bir oyun.
Ama şu anda, o zamandan günümüze
gelip hâlâ oynanan en eski oyun,
Çinlilerin oynadığı Go oyunudur.
Bundan sonra tabii, demin de
bahsettiğim tavlanın çıkışı
İran kökenli olup 6. yüzyıl
ve daha sonrasında hepimizin yine çok
iyi bildiği satranç da milattan sonra
7. yüzyılda Hindistan'da ortaya çıkmış.
Demin bahsettiğim masaüstü oyunlar;
işte Monopoly, Scrubble falan gibi şeyler
daha 19. yüzyıl Sanayi Devrimi
döneminde ortaya çıkmış,
ama şu anda herkesin yine bildiği
masaüstü oyun olarak tabir
edebileceğim Monopoly'nin çıkışı,
Büyük Buhran sonrası bir ekonomik
simülasyondan yola çıkarak ortaya çıkmış.
Ve belki de, hani derler ya kriz
zamanlarında insanlar çok oyun oynuyor;
bunun da belki ilk kökeni Büyük Buhran
sonrasında çıkan bu Milton Bradley
tarafından üretilmiş olan
masaüstü oyunlara kadar gidebilir.
Konumuza biraz daha yaklaşayım.
Bilinen ilk video oyunu,
herkes buna başka bir şey diyor;
kimisi atari diyor, kimisi bilgisayar
oyunu diyor, kimisi video oyunu diyor.
Ben genel video oyunu
terimlerinden bahsetmek istiyorum.
Bilinen ilk video oyunu 1947 yılında
bir osiloskop kullanılarak yapılmış.
Fakat oyunların hayatımıza
daha çok girmesi 1970'li yıllarda,
oyun konsollarının icadıyla ortaya çıkmış.
Bu dönemde Atari, Sega, Nintendo
gibi firmaların ürettiği konsollarla
herkesin evinde televizyona bağlayarak
oyun oynama modası başlamış.
Ama günümüze doğru yaklaştığımızda,
ev bilgisayarlarının artması,
internetin ortaya çıkışı
vesaireyle birlikte
günümüzde şu anda oyun pazarının büyüklüğü
2015 yılı itibari ile 80 milyar dolar.
80 milyar dolar çok ciddi bir rakam
baktığınızda sadece oyun için
insanların dünyada harcadığı.
Bu nerede derseniz, nereye dağılıyor;
bunu herkes esas olarak baktığında,
aa Playstation, aa Xbox, aa Nintendon'un
yeni çıkan konsolu falan diye
konuşabiliyor ama, esas baktığınızda
oyuncuların ağırlığı
PC kullanarak oynuyor.
Ve nerede oynuyor biliyor musunuz?
Ortak PC kullanılan yerler nereleri?
İçinizde kaç kişi internet kafeye gitti
bugüne kadar oyun oynamak için?
Eh, yine %50'yi bulduk.
Eminim büyük bir çoğunluğunuzun evinde
oyun konsolu yoktur, ama oyun oynamak için
pek çok insan internet kafeye gidiyor.
Bu sadece Türkiye'de böyle değil;
dünyada en çok oyuncuyu barındıran
pazar olarak Çin'de de böyle,
Vietnam'da da böyle,
işte başka Güney Doğu Asya ülkelerinin
hemen hemen tamamında böyle.
Kore, birazdan bahsedeceğim,
hem elektronik sporda,
hem de bilgisayar oyunları sektöründe
internet kafeler sayesinde
çok hızlı büyümüş bir pazardır.
Günümüze daha da yaklaştığımızda,
işte oyun firmaları dediler ki
sadece PC oynayanlara gitmeyelim,
biraz daha geniş kitlelere gidelim.
Yediden yetmişe oyun oynatalım,
nerede oynatalım?
Herkesin cebinde bir cep telefonu var.
Orada oyun oynatalım.
Önce yılan oyunu vardır,
yine herkes biliyordur.
Yılan oyunuyla başlayan bir furyayla,
ben onlara dijital tesbih
demeyi tercih ediyorum,
bu dijital tesbihlerle başlayan süreçte,
bugün yediden yetmişe herkes
ya bir Candy Crush oynuyor,
ya bir Clash of Clans oynuyor.
Bir şey oynanıyor yani
gün içinde 5-10 dakika.
Dolayısıyla herkes yediden yetmişe,
oyun oynamaya vakit ayırıyor
ve oyundan zevk alıyor.
Peki, niye oyun oynuyoruz?
Oyun oynamak niye hoşumuza gidiyor?
Niye oyun oynuyorsun diye sorduğunuz
10 kişiden 9'u büyük ihtimalle
''eğleniyorum'' der.
Peki niye eğleniyoruz?
Şimdi şöyle söyleyeyim
insan beynini uzmanlar,
ön lobunu çok güçlü bir
deneyim simülatörü olarak tanımlıyorlar.
İnsan, hayvanların aksine,
birtakım bir şeyleri hayal etmeye,
olmayanı olur gibi görme yeteneğine sahip.
O yüzden de sinemada ya da televizyonda
sevdiğiniz kahraman ölünce ağlıyorsunuz.
Ya da kötü adama
hep beraber hınç duyuyorsunuz.
Sinemada karşılaşmışsınızdır.
Kötü adamı yuhalama gibi şeyler
bizim ülkemizde çok sık olur.
Bu tip şeyler insan olmayanı
var olmuş gibi hissedebilmek
ya da olabilecekleri tasavvur edebilme
yeteneğine sahip.
İşte oyun oynama da,
bu dürtüleri tetikliyor.
Peki hangi dürtüleri tetikliyor?
Evrimsel psikolojide 4 tane ana dürtü var,
aynı zamanda oyunların da tetiklediği.
Bunlardan ilki,
elde etme dürtüsü.
Elde etme dürtüsü,
bireyin bir şeylere sahip olabilmek için,
hayatta bir şeylere sahip olabilmesiyle
tetiklenen bir şey.
Oyunlar da bunun yansıması,
bir oyuncu için ekrandaki karakteri
ya da buradaki örnekte gördüğünüz
benim en çok oynadığım karakter olan
Sona'nın bir DJ Sona kostümü,
benim için piksellerden,
1 ya da 0'lardan ibaret değil.
O benim için bir statü sembolü.
Ona sahip olmak,
onu diğer insanlara göstermek,
arkadaşlarımla paylaşmak
benim için çok çok önemli.
İkinci dürtü, aidiyet dürtüsü.
Bu aidiyet dürtüsünde de,
hep şöyle bir şey vardır;
ya oyunlar asosyal yapıyor.
Ben buna kesinlikle karşıyım, bu
kadar senedir oyun oynayan birisi olarak.
Ben bugün yaptığım işi
oyun oynadığım için yapabiliyorum.
Oyun oynamıyor olsam yapamazdım.
Ama bunun da ötesine gideyim.
Ben oyun oynadığım için Amerika'dan
birtakım insanlarla, Kore'den, Çin'den
birtakım insanlarla tanıştım
ve bu işi buldum.
Bizim ekipte çalışan
herkes de aynı şekilde.
Oyunlar sayesinde benim bugün
Avustralya'dan Brezilya'ya,
Rusya'dan Çin'e kadar arkadaşlarım var.
Dolayısıyla oyunlar bizi asosyalleştirmez,
hatta internet sayesinde küresel köyde
daha yakınlaştırır.
O yüzden de üst resimde gördüğünüz
Samsung White takımında yer alan
5 tane Koreli internet kafesinde
oynayan çocukla,
Türkiye geçen sene şampiyonu olan
Dark Passage, 5 tane Türkiye'deki
internet kafeden bir araya
gelmiş çocuk, ta gidip Tayland'a
Dünya Şampiyonluğu Eleme Maçı
oynayabildiler.
Üçüncüsü, yaratıcılık tarafında
insanları ne dürtülüyor?
Baktığınızda,
siz işte Civilization oynadığınızda,
sıfırdan bir uygarlık kuruyorsunuz.
Bir şeyler yaratıyorsunuz ve o sizde bir
şeyler yaratabilmenin hazzını yaratıyor.
Ya da, şu ekranda gördüğünüz
karmaşa içinde,
saniyenin onda birinde karar verip
doğru hareketi takım arkadaşlarınızla
birlikte strateji geliştirip
uyguluyorsunuz.
Bu da insana ayrı bir tatmin veriyor.
Son olarak da, savunma duygusu.
Bu normal hayatta insanın
başını belaya sokmaması için,
yani arabanızla trafikte
180 basmaya çalışmıyorsunuz,
ya da kendinizi götürüp
bir köprüden aşağı atmıyorsunuz.
Çünkü bireyin kendini koruma
ve savunma duygusu var.
Oysa ki oyunlarda bu,
biraz daha farklı tezahür ediyor.
Oyunun doğasında sizin normal hayatta
almayacağınız riskleri
alabilme duygusu var.
Ama bu riskler size
sürekli oyunu kaybettiriyorsa,
o oyun sizin için zevkli olmaz.
Ya da başka bir şekilde
oyun eğer çok kolaysa,
yani Playstation oynarken sürekli orta
sahadan her vurduğunuz top gol oluyorsa,
bir süre sonra oyunu oynamazsınız.
O yüzden oyun tasarımcıları,
bugün bu dengeyi kurmak için
sürekli kafa yoruyorlar.
Bu denge ne kadar güzel oturursa,
o zaman siz bu oyunu 5 saat,
10 saat değil; 1000 saat, 2000 saat,
3000 saat oynuyorsunuz.
Olayın spor tarafına geleyim.
Şimdi ben kendimi
oyuncu olarak tanımladım.
İkinci olarak da kendimi spor izleyicisi
olarak tanımlamayı çok seviyorum.
Mahalle arasında çocuklar halı sahada
oynarken de görürsem seyrederim,
televizyonda eşimin deyimiyle
''köy maçı'' bulsam da seyrederim.
Snooker bile sevdiğim bir spor dalıdır
ve tahminim Türkiye'de herhalde beyzbolu
severek izleyen 10-15 kişiden biriyim.
Çünkü spor,
benim için bir oyun ve oyunlarla sporun
pek çok ortak özelliği var.
Günün sonunda baktığınızda,
olimpiyat oyunlarıdır o tüm dünyayı
4 yılda bir ekran başına toplayan
büyük organizasyonun adı.
O yüzden de,
ben konuşmamın son kısmında
sizlere elektronik spordan
detaylıca bahsetmek istiyorum.
Bu ekranda gördüğünüz 5 genç arkadaş,
Beşiktaş Elektronik Spor Takımı.
Ve burada gördüğünüz
ellerinde kaldırdıkları kalkan,
aynen şu anda benim durduğum ya da
belki bir iki adım geride duruyorlardı,
sahnede durarak bundan 4 hafta önce
Brezilya şampiyonunu yenip kaldırdıkları
kalkan.
Bunu yaptıktan sonra dünyanın
en iyi 6 takımından biri olarak,
Amerika'ya Flo Rida'ya gidip ülkemizi
özel bir turnuvada temsil ettiler.
Peki, ne yaptılar da kazandılar?
League of Legends adındaki
oyunu oynayarak kazandılar.
League of Legends nedir diye şöyle
kısaca size bahsedecek olursam,
arkamda gördüğünüz haritanın
iki ucunda iki tane kule, merkez var.
Beşer kişilik takımlar halinde,
strateji geliştirerek karşı tarafın
kalesini yok etmeye çalışıyorsunuz.
Her oyunda, şu üst köşede gördüğünüz
karakterlerden birini seçiyorsunuz.
Dolayısıyla beş kişinin
seçeceği karakterler,
onlara karşı seçilen karakterler,
onların hepsinin özellikleri,
oyuna ne şekilde başlayacağınız,
oyunun hangi alanında
ne yapacağınızın önceden belirlenmesiyle
sonsuz sayıda seçenek
ve strateji geliştirme imkânı oluyor.
Ve bunu da gayet güzel insanlar salona
toplanıp ekranları başında ya da salonda
izleyebiliyor.
Hatta bunların spora benzeyen yerleri,
mevkileri de var oyuncuların.
Mesela bakın üst koridor oyuncusu.
Alt koridordaki saldırı gücü taşıyıcısı,
ona destek,
orman oyuncusu ve orta koridor oyuncusu
gibi bunların mevkileri de var.
Bu arkadaşların hepsi,
profesyonel oyuncu.
Profesyonel oyuncu ne demek?
Türkiye'de bir
profesyonel elektronik spor ligi var.
Burada Beşiktaş'ın da
aralarında bulunduğu 8 takım,
her hafta bu iş için özel olarak
tasarlanmış arenada bir araya geliyorlar.
Bu arenada oynuyorlar
ve bu maçlar internetten yayınlanıyor.
Ortalama her hafta bu maçları,
bu tip profesyonel liglerdeki maçları
1 milyon tekil izleyici takip ediyor.
Ve burada bu arkadaşlar
bir yandan maç oynuyorlar,
bir yandan da oynadıkları maç başına
para kazanıyorlar.
Yani baktığınızda hepsinin
maçların sonunda kazandıkları
kupalar ve ödüllerin yanında,
maaşları da var.
Tam anlamıyla birer
profesyonel sporcu olmuş durumdalar.
Normal sporlardan tabii elektronik sporun
çok ciddi farklılıkları da var.
Bu arkadaşlar maç oynamadıkları
zamanlar, oyun evi denen
''gaming house''larda yaşıyorlar.
Gaming house'larda yaşamanın ötesinde;
burada hem antrenman yapıyorlar,
hem işte sponsorları ile görüşüyorlar.
Çünkü her takımın 5 tane has oyuncusu,
yedek oyuncusunun yanında;
koçu, mentorü, pazarlama ekibi,
malzemecisi bilgisayar bozulduğu
zaman tamir edecek
gibi arkadaşlar da var.
Ve bu arkadaşlar bu evlerde oynarken
aynı zamanda diğer spor dallarında
görmediğimiz bir şey de yapıyorlar.
Akşam antrenman yaparken,
antrenmanlarını internet üzerinden
yayınlıyorlar ve bu yayınladıkları,
yaptıkları yayınlara reklam alarak,
ciddi ek gelir sağlayabiliyorlar.
Bunu normal sporda şöyle anlatabilirim.
Ronaldo'nun Real Madrid antrenmanına
çıkarken kafasına bir tane
kamera taktığını düşünün.
Bir yandan antrenman yapıyor,
bir yandan da seyircilerden gelen sorulara
anında cevap veriyor
ve sohbet ediyor onlarla.
Dolayısıyla klasik sporlarda
çok fazla olmayan bir durum,
ama günümüzün modern atletleri
bu noktada.
Şu anda, o kadar büyük bir hâle
geldi ki elektronik spor dediğimiz,
şu anda 67 milyon insan
her ay League of Legends oynuyor.
Bu, 3.5 milyar saatlik
bir oyuna denk geliyor.
Demin bahsettiğim bu
Beşiktaş'ın İNTZ takımını yendiği maçı,
1.8 milyon kişi canlı seyretti.
Canlı seyretti derken, internetten
biz bu maçların hepsini yayınlıyoruz.
Ve bu sahnenin aktörleri de,
bir kısmı içinizde oturuyor,
spikerler ve yorumcular.
Normalde bir futbol maçına gittiğinizde,
maçı seyredersiniz, kimse size
ne olup ne bittiğini anlatmaz.
Ama bu sahnede,
elektronik spor maçı oynanırken,
şurada kurulu bir podyum üstünde,
3 yorumcu ve 2 spiker arkadaşımız
burada gördüğünüz
şekilde maçı anlatıyorlar,
pozisyonları yorumluyorlar.
Hem seyirciye konuyla ilgili
bilgi veriyorlar,
hem de seyirciyle birlikte
aksiyonun bir parçası oluyorlar.
Bu da diğer spor dallarında
pek görmediğimiz bir şey.
Türkiye'de biz bunları yapıyoruz.
Senede işte 4-5 tane etkinlik yapıyoruz.
Her birine 10-15 bin kişi
getirebiliyoruz canlı olarak ama,
bu baktığınızda Kore'deki
Dünya Şampiyonası Finali.
20 bin kişi Kore'deki stadyumda
bir araya geldi.
Çin takımı ve Kore takımının
birbiriyle mücadelesini izlediler.
Sonunda demin de bahsettiğim gibi
bu işe hakikaten çok büyük bir
hırsla yatırım yapan
Kore'nin Samsung White takımı,
dünya şampiyonu oldu.
Bir milyon dolar ödülü kazandı
ve bu seneye şampiyon olarak girdi.
Bu sene şampiyona Berlin'de yapılacak,
bakalım kim kazanacak.
Ama şöyle söyleyeyim,
Çinlilerin ve Korelilerin o kadar büyük
bir mesafe katetmiş durumdalar ki;
biz Türkiye olarak, Beşiktaş'ın yanında
Galatasaray ve Fenerbahçe de girse bu işe,
daha bizim o arayı kapatmamız, bayağı bir
çalışmamız gerekecek diye düşünüyorum.
Demin de bahsettiğim gibi.
Thaldrin ve Theokoles
modern çağın atletleri.
Yaptıkları işe biz
''elektronik spor'' diyoruz.
Bu yeni bir mecrada,
rekabetçi bir aksiyon.
Buna spor diyebilirsiniz.
Ya bunun nesi spor, diyebilirsiniz.
Bu tamamen size kalmış.
Buna ne dersek diyelim,
şu anda bunu tüm dünyada
milyonlarca kişi oynuyor
ve milyonlarca kişi
büyük bir zevkle izliyor,
sizlerin de ilgisini çektiyse,
sizleri de bu eğlenceye katılmaya
davet ediyorum.
Dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)